олексій гончаренко європейська
солідарність що але мені друзі парять
початком усієї сесії вийшла фантастичне
інтерв'ю нашого президента за ленського
американському хаті мислить ти брата
прорахунку знав ще що за ленський кишки
зли на трампа але звичайно трамп
президент можна буде вирішити злим і вона
була там худоби дякую
адміністрації трампа дізналася таємницю з
бровою для україни за спину боротьбу
проти первинного потоку 2
я б сказати і було дякую адміністрації
байдена протеза а сьогодні он і ставити
україну у Польщі пріоритет орігамі схеми
почуєте ви не дружини вакцину та м'язи
живіт стає бангладеш і алжир то
Європа ви на Євсіно в половині я самий
просто фантастичний пасаж записів
ленський сказавши про крим я вважав винза
ленський був президентом чотирнадцятого
роті вінка ж ми б всі склу та кров'ю
надала б їх чоловічків би в криму не
пропустив та зрозуміло він досі зуб та
не лап результаті все
хоч хтось у наш, але ж не воїн
амазонка
мета балади мур-мур мати який би всіх
зуб і не входь у чотирнадцятому росі
знаєте все взяла з Києва президентом
польші в тридцять дев'ятому уроці я так
розумію інший світловий вин ібн абу лоб
мета воїн кліпу гладка людина на це
щоб зустріч за ленський cool українці
стікали кров'ю на донбасі вин стіків
потім на зйомках пальцях 8 побачимо в
росії тіла черевики наводжу за віденський вам
взяти з бравого ягра він один і на україни
пити та захищати україну чесного жало to
die борід і все за україну вона зарості
троянд navidad та я був у криму у kenshi
люто 14 року я пунктом разом з порошенком
я бачив там і обживайся мустафа джемілів
я боровся артемчик гост
народний депутат та у європейській
солідарності та зразка рефат чубарів
депутація кіндера загул блоку петра
порошенка обдурили каденції шосе на
плащі вас там володимир олександрович у
діви bull та я вас там не бачив я був
наділені ти довго суворих аксонів на так
званий світ з трендами в різні мережі в
крыму bus українським прапором та ви були
я patcher зроблених чоловічків та ще
однієї залаїн 100 до мене на допомогу їх до
випав і колимагу поранив і донбас та ви
були калуга зворушила доставить російського
іншого ви знаєте розправі дати і знімався
у ролі наполеона i bought in аполлоном
c2
у таборі знаєте і опинюся в одесі навіть
ви в тому інтерв'ю сказав і щоб облогові
харчування до байдена ніж у мене в нато а в
нас українців 1 та харчування для вас ніс
воїн amazon до чого ви ще президент
україни тарас